[Musique]
Messieurs, bonjour. Je vous interview
aujourd'hui pour un site internet qui
s'appelle Serview. J'aurais j'aurais
voulu avoir votre avis sur le concept de
cyberguerre de cyberpai. Qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire là-dessus ?
Je je peux commencer là-dessus. On s'est
fait bassiner pendant des années avec ce
concept de cybergerre qui correspond à
une forme de de militarisation de
l'Internet. Le déploiement
d'infrastructure. On pense au joujou
d'AMS6 à la Deep Packet Inspection des
dispositions législatives pour donner
des pouvoirs offensifs en matière de de
cyberattaque maintenant en France à LAN
et des institutions dans le monde
entier. C'est des c'est la commande
publique qui part avec des des contrats
je ne sais combien de zéro pour les
mêmes entreprises euh qui vendent des
des missiles et et des et des chasseurs.
Euh le problème c'est quand on parle de
cybergerre, on parle d'internet comme un
champ de bataille, on parle de de
mouvement de troupe, on oublie juste un
paramètre qui est le citoyen. Et pendant
des années, on nous a vendu une vision
de la sécurité, de la cybersécurité qui
s'appelait cybergre dans laquelle on a
juste oublié les citoyens. Et
aujourd'hui, on s'aperçoit avec la
révélation de Snowden euh le le
programme Bullrun de la NSA euh qui vise
à saboter activement une par une toutes
les technologies commerciales de
protection de nos données de
communication. On s'aperçoit aujourd'hui
qu'on a tous un espion dans la poche.
Est-ce que vous pouvez un petit peu me
développer le programme lustre ? Au-delà
au-delà des différents programmes de de
de la NSA, on constate l'échec des
politiques de cybersécurité.
La seule chose à laquelle ça a servi,
c'est à des contrats euh d'un complexe
militaro industriel qu'il va falloir
renommer, je sais pas le complexe
militaroon numérique ou quelque chose
comme ça. Alors que personne n'a pensé à
développer la cyberpaix. La
cyberpaix se basé sur la définition de
la paix. La paix c'est un état dans
lequel on est libre de la peur de
l'agression. Qu'est-ce que ça voudrait
dire dans l'environnement numérique être
libre de la peur de l'agression ? Ça
veut dire mettre le citoyen au cœur de
la sécurité. Ça veut dire mettre le
citoyen au cœur de la technologie. Ça
veut dire rendre le le contrôle de la
technologie aux citoyens. Et bien, on
aspire à des politiques publiques qui
penseraient en terme de cyberfai plutôt
qu'en terme de cybergerre. Éc Filiol,
est-ce que vous pouvez Moi, je crois que
ce conseil de cyber de cybergerre soit
probablement que la la plus grosse
escroquerie intellectuelle de ces
dernières années. Quand on Moi, je vais
me placer sur le plan purement
opérationnel, euh je pense que la partie
cyberne, qui est une dimension
supplémentaire à la fin du 20e siècle,
comme l'a été l'aviation au début au
début du du 20e, ne jouera qu'un rôle
marginal ou d'appui ou de préparation
sur des conflits classiques. Faut pas
oublier que la guerre consiste à prendre
la possession de de de réalité bien
matérielle, que ce soit des territoires,
que ce soi des ressources et que ce soit
aussi des esprits. Et il faut pas
oublier que la finalité de la guerre,
c'est prendre c'est justement de prendre
la main sur les réalités concrètes. Donc
le cyber à mon avis restera marginal. Ça
peut pas dire qu'il faut le comment
s'appelle le relativiser ni le
dédaigner. C'est une réalité qui
s'impose à nous. Mais elle n'a pas
l'ampleur qu'on veut bien lui prêter. Et
je suis d'accord que c'est plus pour
légitimer des alors d'une part des
dépenses pharaoniques dans le domaine,
mais je crois que surtout euh plus
qu'une cybergarre, je crois qu'on est en
train en mettre en place des
cyberdictatures et et pour développer.
Bah, on s'aperçoit que le programme
Prisme, mais
Prisme existe a eu des des antécédents.
On s'avère qu'il y a quand même
une les principales
démocraties ont tendance à se à se
tourner en état policier numérique. Et
moi ce qui me gêne dans les évolutions
récentes, c'est qu'on on remplace la
présomption d'innocence par la
présomption de culpabilité. quand on
espionne toutes les personnes par
défaut, pas seulement des communications
téléphoniques parce que vous avez un
contact avéré avec des terroristes corse
ou des terroristes islamique. Euh quand
on espionne en permanence euh je veux
dire moins dans gest, il faut savoir
qu'avec l'internet connecté et notamment
le CP outdoor, c'est-à dire que de
l'extérieur, on pour savoir ce qui se
passe dans votre maison, votre
consommation électrique et les outils
mathématiques de traitement de la
formation vont le permettre. Quand on
espionne en permanence et de manière
aussi intime les gens, c'est qu'on part
du principe que ils sont par coupable
défaut par défaut coupable ou
susceptible de perpéter des actes. On
peut pas avoir un état fort, un état
doit être fort mais sans faire confiance
aux citoyens, sans les laisser libres et
sans les respecter. Et si on se méfie
des citoyens, les citoyens se méfieront
de l'État et on aura un état fait.
Récemment, un cryptographe belge a
annoncé que lui-même
était piraté par la NSA, poutré dans le
dans le jargon. Qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ? Bah, ce qui me surprend, c'est
que ça surprenne encore des
gens. Euh c'est logique. En plus, ce
cryptographe belge est bien connu pour
avoir eu des activités mathématiques
sensibles. C'est aussi quelqu'un qui a
une époque c'est n'a pas voulu aller
dans le sens du contrôle de la
cryptographie. notamment universitaire
par les milieux américains. Alors tout
simplement, c'est quelqu'un qui compte
dans le domaine qui a eu une production
scientifique de tout premier
plan, qui a d'ailleurs eu des qui a été
pillé à l'époque puisquil faut savoir
qu' il a eu il avait fait avec un autre
cryptologue français Guillou, le fameux
protocole Guill squatter qui a été pillé
par une entreprise américaine en
violation directe des brevets. Sauf que
trois avocats français contre 50 avocats
américains, la cause était vite
entendue. Donc c'est pas étonnant qu'il
était espionné. Mais encore une fois, ce
qui m'étonne c'est qu'on ça étonne
encore des gens. Qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dire un petit peu
sur la capacité que les gens eux-mêmes,
le simple particulier a à se protéger de
ce genre de de pillage de d'infiltration
dans dans son système
? Il y a deux choses distinctes. Euh la
surveillance ciblée et la surveillance
de masse. Euh j'espère que les
prochaines révélation Snowden nous
montreront d'une part comment on peut
passer de l'un à l'autre. Est-ce que le
simple fait de ne pas utiliser Facebook,
Google ou Apple ne vous met pas
immédiatement dans la catégorie
surveillance ciblée pourquoi que vous
utilisiez des logiciels libres ou tort ?
Et là ça fait de vous un un potentiel
terroriste. Mais il faut encore
distinguer les deux. La surveillance
ciblée, on le voit avec les les
dernières révélations euh sur les
implants matériels et autres joujou de
la NSA, on savait déjà on ne peut pas y
échapper. Euh ça c'est c'est une
réalité. Euh la surveillance ciblée est
légitime lorsqu'encadrée par l'autorité
judiciaire, lorsqu'il y a un
rétrocontrôle
citoyen et
démocratique des actions, des services
qui qui la pratiquent. Euh ce qui est
véritablement intolérable, c'est la
surveillance de masse. Comme le disait
Eric Fillol, c'est la présomption de
culpabilité.
C'est des violations massives de nos
libertés individuelles qui ne peuvent en
aucun cas respecter le principe de
proportionnalité. Or, cette surveillance
de masse, a priori, on peut y échapper.
Est-ce que vous allez dans le sens
d'Éric Filiol sur la cyberdictature d'un
gouvernement ou des gouvernements qui
commencent à avoir peur de leurs propres
concitoyens et qui commencent à
monitorer l'ensemble de leur population
? C'est manifeste la doctrine de la NSA,
c'est que l'ennemi se situant par
définition dans le reste du monde, on va
espionner le reste du monde comme ça, on
aura après coup espionné nos ennemis.
C'est c'est une doctrine qui est une
forme de paranoïa d'état et et c'est
évidemment un problème. Le le fait est
que l'on peut aujourd'hui probablement
échapper à cette surveillance de masse
et c'est ça l'enjeu aujourd'hui, c'est
d'augmenter le coût de cette
surveillance ou de tenter de la rendre
inopérante par nos actions. la
différence des des processus classiques
dans lesquels on voyait intervenir le
renseignement ou l'armée, donc c'était
souvent armée contre armée, état contre
état, là la la vaste majorité des
acteurs, c'est les citoyens. Et
euh vous parlez de citoyen, vous parlez
de citoyens, vous sortez d'une
conférence que vous avez mené à
Sciencepo est-ce que vous avez trouvé
les étudiants sensibles à ce type de de
nouvelles valeurs, ce type de de menace
? Est-ce que vous pensez qu'ils étaient
en retard par rapport à la perception
que la communauté des hackers peut avoir
sur la cybersécurité, sur les techniques
de surveillance de masse et ce ce genre
de chos ? Est-ce que vous pensez que la
nouvelle génération est prête à résister
ou est prête à trouver les nouveaux
outils pour pouvoir échapper à ce type
de surveillance ? Je sais pas si si une
heure avec une promo d'un master de
science po est un échantillon
représentatif. Une chose dont je suis
sûr, c'est que sur les les 10 jours qui
viennent de s'écouler, il y a cinq
personnes qui sont venu me voir en
disant "Ah ben tu sais quoi ? J'ai
quitté Facebook et pour beaucoup ils
m'ont dit c'est suite à une conversation
qu'on avait eu ensemble dans ces
derniers mois c'est des dizaines de
journalistes que j'ai vu se mettre à OT
ou à JPG pour chiffrer leur
communication et c'est 100 % des
journalistes à qui j'ai parlé de la
protection de leurs sources qui m'ont
répondu "Ah ouais c'est vrai, là on a un
problème". Éric Philiol. Éric Filiol.
Jérémy parle de chiffrement pour la
protection des sources. Qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire en tant qu'expert
avec votre qualité d'expertise de
cryptographe ? Est-ce que les
journalistes sont à l'abri ? Alors, il
est sûr que d'abord c'est mieux que de
communiquer en clair. Ça complique les
idées, ça complique les choses.
Maintenant, il faut, je crois qu'il faut
faut pas se voler la face que la plupart
des standards de chiffrement sont
d'obédience américaine et que la
subtilité américaine a été de c'est la
politique des œufs du panier. Ils n'ont
pas placé toutes les vulnérabilités au
même endroit. Moi ce qui me gêne c'est
que ben l'ensemble de la planète utilise
des algorithmes d'obéience américaine et
uniquement
cela. J'ai vu un constructeur que je ne
nommerai pas qui avait fait le choix
d'algorithme de chiffrement non
américain et qui quand il a été racheté
par une une société américaine a été
obligé de mettre la. Donc le problème
c'est que on laisse aux
États-Unis le monopole des des de toute
la standardisation. Moi, je conteste le
fait que les Américains définissent le
standard cryptologique mondial. Je pense
qu'il y a de très bons cryptologues en
France, il y en a partout en Europe.
Pourquoi devrait-on sous-traiter notre
sécurité et les standards de
chiffrement aux Américains ? Est-ce que
vous trouvez que c'est un renoncement de
l'État français ? Pas que de l'État
français, de l'ensemble des pays du G8,
du G20. Il est sûr qu'en France, c'est
d'autant plus surprenant qu'on pas dire
scandaleux quand on est des nations
prééminentes en matière de cryptologie.
Donc on a l'École normale supérieure
produit des des cerveaux extrêmement
brillants. Le problème c'est que pour
une place dans un comité de programme
dans des conférence américaine sous
contrôle la NSA ben malheureusement ils
font le jeu des des États-Unis. Nous
avons une capacité de réaction, nous
avons une capacité de résistance, nous
avons un génie français. Il ne faut pas
l'oublier. On peut pas sousraiter notre
sécurité. En tout cas, on fera jamais de
sécurité si on utilise les méthodes, les
standards, les outils d'adversaire.
Jammerman voulaz rebondir. Je n'aime pas
parler de souveraineté à proprement
parler parce que bon le concept d'état
nation est pas ce qui me pas ce qui me
m'anime le plus ou me définit le plus.
Mais là, il y a quelque chose vraiment
flagrant à voir la souveraineté d'un
état tiers euh non seulement en piété
sur la souveraineté d'autres États, mais
aussi sur la souveraineté des individus,
sur nos souverainetés informationnelles.
Donc là, il y a
manifestement un un espace pour des
politiques publiques à tenter d'inverser
cette cette vapeur là. Et le seul moyen
de faire ça, j'en suis convaincu, c'est
de remettre la technologie aux mains des
citoyens. Il faut que les citoyens
comprennent l'importance de la vie
privée pour comprendre l'intérêt de la
cryptographie, pour comprendre comment
gérer les clés de chiffrement et pour
éventuellement être en position de
choisir leur logiciel de chiffrement ou
le choisir leur algorithme. Quand on
génère une fg, on peut choisir entre
plusieurs algorithmes. Et bien, j'ai
l'impression qu'il est essentiel
aujourd'hui d'élever le niveau de
conscience des individus d'une part et
de l'autre qu'il faut des des politique
publique, des politiques industrielles
pour aller favoriser ces technologies
qui ne sont pas aux mains de la NSA qui
reposent évidemment sur le logiciel
libre, les architectures décentralisées
et le chiffrement point. Le mot de la
fin, Éric Fillol.
Ce qui me moi ce qui me fait peur c'est
que on a vu en 95 que on pouvait très
vite basculer d'un gouvernement
démocratique à un gouvernement non
démocratique.
Quand on met en place des
infrastructures, quand on met en place
potentiellement du moins des outils de
surveillance, je pense à Adopi, ça a
l'air un Odin, mais ADOPI peut permettre
à quelqu'un non seulement de savoir que
le télécharge du contenu est
potentiellement illégal, mais de savoir
que vous intéressez à l'art africain, à
l'art juif et ce qui est tout à fait
légitime. Demain, c'est un risque qui
est permanent et j'ai été surpris de
voir que les situations SPR n'étaient
pas sensibilisées à ça. Ce risque, il
est permanent. On peut très bien
basculer vers un régime beaucoup moins
démocratique avec des valeurs nausées à
bonde. Et je crois que l'actualité
récemment a montré que encore une fois
qu'on était pas si éloigné que ça, ce
qui me fait peur, c'est que tout ce que
l'on met en place ma peur a été utilisée
légitimement par justement ces
gouvernements moins démocratiques s'il
venaient au pouvoir et pourrait bah
automatiser un génocide ou automatiser
des arrestations en masse. Et c'est ça
qui me fait peur. Tant qu'on est dans un
état démocratique, je crois que je veux
faire bien je veux bien faire confiance
à nos états. Eric Filal, Jérémie
Zimmerman. Peut-être que un dernier mot
? Oui. Tant que ces états restent
démocrati. Jérémy un dernier mot sûr.
Quand on parle de protection de la vie
privée, on parle d'une liberté plus
fondamentale que les autres parce
qu'elle permet l'exercice des des autres
libertés et que cette cette vie privée,
c'est avant tout notre nos intimités.
Nos intimités, c'est un espace dans
lequel on n'est pas jugé, dans lequel on
partage la confiance et dans laquelle on
peut expérimenter, dans lequel on peut
inventer de nouvelles idées, de nouveaux
concepts dans lequel on peut être
nous-même. Cette vie privée, cette
intimité, c'est nos identités. C'est ce
qui nous définit en tant qu'être humain.
Et c'est ça qui est en jeu, je je crois,
au travers de de cet impératif de
reprendre le contrôle de la technologie.
C'est reprendre le contrôle de la
technologie pour reprendre le contrôle
de nos humanités. Au contraire se
laisser contrôler par la machine.
Charerman, merci Éric Filiol, merci.
L'analphabétisme aujourd'hui, c'est le
code. Si vous savez pas coder, vous êtes
un analphabète. Au même titre qu'il y a
plein d'analphabètes au 18e siècle en
France. Un analpha web. Euh vous êtes un
alphabè, vraiment analphabè. C'est vous
avez pas codé. C'est à peu près aussi
handicapant pour le monde qui arrive
devant vous. que de ne pas savoir lire
au 18e siècle. Est-ce que l'économie
américaine va
continuer à une faible croissance ? Je
dirais que c'est probable et que leur
principal handicap est la finance. On ne
peut plus parler du poids de la parole
diplomatique française au Moyen-Orient.
Elle n'existe plus. C'est la parole
américaine. Ils sont devenus
des-paroles de la parole américaine.
[Musique]